bonsoir françois bonneau merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
en 2010 9 lors d'une audition nationale
général lecointe chef d'état-major des
armées disait je cite l'armée de l'air
va devenir de plus en plus une armée de
pilotes de drones prophétie ou cris
d'appel pour s'améliorer dans ce domaine
tout à fait une prophétie on va
clairement vers ceux là où on va aussi
via tous les systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle vers des systèmes de
systèmes où on utilisera encore des
avions des avions de combat où les
avions sans pilote mais aussi un
accompagnement très très lié aux drones
et et aussi aux satellites
le rapport de la commission de la
défense du sénat s'intitule je cite se
préparer à la guerre des drones un enjeu
stratégique c'est à dire quoi les
conflits armés classics et c'est du
passé
le terme enjeu stratégique ça veut dire
quoi exactement
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui on le voit
bien avec avec barkan dans la zone
sahélo sahélienne on est dans un conflit
asymétrique où on a une maîtrise du ciel
mais on sait bien que l'environnement
international est quand même très
compliqué à l'heure actuelle et on peut
pas ignorer qu'on peut être dans un
conflit symétrique ou là n'auront pas
forcément la maîtrise du ciel et qu'on
doit se préparer par rapport à ce que
vous avez évoqué les conflits précédents
et si on n'est pas prêts au niveau de
deux des drones à la fois pour en
posséder mais aussi pour les détecter
ceux des deux puissances ennemies on
serait en grande fragilité et d'ailleurs
vous laïcité avec l'harmonica qui a
perdu énormément de charme dans ce
conflit est capable plus utiliser ces
parties aériennes comme israël la chine
la turquie et l'iran se sont lancés dans
la production à grande échelle
et à l'exportation aussi de drones dit
de bon marché comment est-ce que se
positionne la france dans ce domaine
parce que la france est en avance est ce
qu'elle est en retard
on rappelle quand même que paris est 3e
ou 4e exportateur d'armes dans le monde
alors en fait la france dispose d'un
environnement technique et technologique
de très grande qualité et donc et et est
en capacité de produire à la fois des
des drones mais aussi les tous les
systèmes qui les accompagnent il se
trouve que effectivement on a on a un
retard sur sur le remplacement du reaper
keita qui est un drone américain
tactique et que l'on utilise notamment
sur la base de niamey au niger
mais l'euro drôle petit doigt le teaser
remplacé lui n'arrivera qu'en 2000 28
c'est une coopération européenne mais
qui effectivement tarde un peu et il est
il est important que nous soyons prêts
sachant que sur les petits drones qui
eux aussi sont essentiels pour toutes
aux armes et là là on comble le retard
rapidement et sur ce segment
effectivement on a en a deux on a de
très beaux seins des drones qui sont
tout à fait pertinents et efficaces dans
les domaines d'intervention qui sont les
leurs
et là effectivement on va rattraper un
retard mais qui est tout relatif
le rapport qui est présenté aujourd'hui
parlent de drones offensif ou défensif
pour les opérations extérieures certes
mais aussi pour le territoire national
sa veux dire quoi exactement à quoi
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre on va voir
des drones au dessus de nos têtes pour
faire quoi alors ce qu'on veut surtout
c'est protéger le territoire national
avec un certain nombre de d'emprise vous
à vous avez cité les centrales
nucléaires mais il ya d'autres sites
sensibles sur lesquels il faut à la fois
qu'on ait des systèmes de détection
alors ça a été fait cet effet au niveau
des oeuvres port aujourd'hui avec 6,1
basalte quiconque sonne bien
mais il est clair il faut que compte
tenu aujourd'hui du nombre de drones qui
exponentielle on est à la fois des
systèmes de détection mais aussi des
système de neutralisation qui sont dans
des environnements très particulier sur
territoire national et sur lequel on
peut bien évidemment pas opérer sans
avoir un certain nombre d'autorisations
qui nous permettrait d'intervenir à ce
qu'ils disent faites l'amour pas la
guerre et utiliser le budget de la
défense pour des politiques plus sociale
et plus humaine qu'est ce que vous leur
répondre c'est déjà les romains qui
disait si tu veux la paix prépare la
guerre je crois que si si si on doit si
on doit effectivement être litim date à
coups d'interventions que ce soit
d'ailleurs nous nos partenaires
européens il faut absolument qu'on soit
prêt et on l'a lu il ya quand même des
pays qui ont cure énormément investi
dans ses nouvelles à vous avez vous
l'avez évoqué que ce soit la turquie
israël l'iran la chine qui sont qui sont
aujourd'hui avec une capacité d'action
au niveau des drones qui tout à fait
dangereuse pour des adversaires
potentiels donc donc on doit absolument
être prêt à toute éventualité un sens
sans dire que c'est forcément ces pays
qui avec qui nous ont rien d confirmé
enfin en tout cas peut aujourd'hui
mettre à dispo mettre à disposition et
vous l'avez évoqué sur l'azerbaïdjan
on met à disposition auprès des azéri
des des systèmes de drones extrêmement
efficace et qui ont causé des pertes
très importantes aux armées merci
françois bonneau d'avoir répondu à une
question je rappelle que vous êtes à la
sénateur centriste de la charente membre
de la commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense et des forces armées